orange juice made from Florida oranges
might be disappearing from store shelves
this has sent frozen concentrate orange
juice Futures to record highs and led to
thousands of job Cuts billions of
dollars lost for the state and bigger
risks that have scared away some Futures
Traders
the impact is so far-reaching because
orange juice isn't just a breakfast
drink it relies on a real world
commodity that has propped up an entire
industry for decades here's what
Florida's dying oranges can tell us
about how the commodity Market works and
how it impacts the price you pay for
orange juice
yeah
a commodity is a basic good used in
Commerce that usually refers to a raw
material used to manufacture finished
goods so think Lumber gold oil and
frozen concentrate orange juice which
became a commodity following World War
II researchers were trying to find ways
to give soldiers in the United States
military ways to drink tasty juice that
also had the added benefit of giving
them vitamins by evaporating some of the
water from orange juice then freezing
and packaging that frozen concentrate
orange juice the commodity was invented
shipment is in refrigerated trucks and
trains only to keep the product Frozen
until the can is opened in the kitchen
and the water is put back in because
it's something that is widely processed
widely available and is generally of
equal value or quality depending on
where you are that's something that
could be traded following this invention
Florida's orange industry really boomed
throughout the late 1990s dozens of
orange juice processing plants were
built across the state depending on the
season more than 90 percent of the
country's orange juice was made from
florida-grown oranges you had Florida
oranges on the state's license plates
you have the Florida Orange Bowl which
is the one of the most famous college
football games played outside of Miami
each year
Miami Florida plays host to a half
million Spectators on the eve of the
Orange Bowl game in addition to this
actual hard commodity that we have
oranges at the end of the day you really
see in the case of Florida them growing
into this large cultural phenomenon
commodity trading often revolves around
Futures contracts an agreement between
two parties for a delivery of a
commodity at a future date these tend to
run on a monthly basis
when prices go up that tends to mean
either there's a huge shock to supply or
it means there's surging demand in
Florida's case a bacterial disease
called Citrus Greening has been killing
orange trees since the early 2000s that
plus a freeze and two hurricanes last
year have led to the state's worst
harvest in nearly 90 years demand for
orange juice has actually gone down over
the years but because Florida's orange
production has plummeted so much prices
have actually gone up orange juice
manufacturers are also increasingly
using oranges from Mexico and Brazil
because Florida's supply has gotten so
low over the last couple of years the US
dollar has been particularly strong
which basically means that we can have
our dollars go further abroad so imports
from places like Brazil and Mexico have
become effectively cheaper which adds
more pressure on Florida oranges so why
trade a commodity like frozen
concentrate orange juice well for the
farmer and the manufacturer buying
Futures contracts protects them from
fluctuations in the market so if the
price does in fact fall you've locked in
some of your output at a certain level
so you're not going to Bear the full
brunt of those losses commodity markets
are dependent on a lot of natural
factors that are unforeseen and out of
people's control and one of the ways
that Traders try to limit some of the
volatility that comes with that is by
exchanging Futures contracts financial
traders aim to profit off that
volatility by placing bets on which way
they think the market will swing that
was the premise of the 1983 movie
trading places where the main characters
made a fortune betting on the frozen
concentrate orange juice Market the cold
winter has apparently not affected the
orange Harvest
but what happens in commodity markets
doesn't just affect these three groups
when Futures prices are high
manufacturers pay more for contracts
which means they charge retailers more
who then charge consumers more given the
trends that we're seeing from Florida it
seems that the prices will only continue
to go upward
[Music]